a lot of people who listen to this but
in general in the united states practice
brazilian jiu jitsu
which has a lot of similarities to judo
as obviously its origins in judo
how would you compare the two arts from
the perspective of people just
interested about both arts
do you recommend people who do jiu jitsu
get into judo
how can they enrich their jiu jitsu how
do you compare the two arts the actual
practice of it and why it might be
useful to you
i mean i think that judo is a hard sport
for adults to do um it just is you know
especially people that are haven't
fallen in a long time haven't you aren't
very athletic you know haven't
i think i think about my own experience
right outs other than judo when did i
ever do like a forward somersault maybe
when i was in grade school right that's
the last time i've left my feet was in
grade school
most people haven't got off of a chair
or a couch they spend eight to ten hours
a day either working behind a computer
or sitting on a college watching tv
right and they're not that athletic and
they haven't done anything athletic at
least
probably since high school yeah right
that's their last athletic endeavor most
of them so you're talking about as an
adult that's 35 or 40 wanting to start a
sport judo is a really hard sport to
start especially in today's
dojos that don't have a recreational
adult program
or you know when it's one size fits all
it's hard so for those people jiu-jitsu
makes a heck of a lot of sense
good self-defense
it's cerebral where you got to use your
brain you're smaller person you have to
use technique you know you know it
teaches all the same things as judo but
it's a safe way to do it and
because of the validation it has with
the ufc and mma today right everybody
knows jiu-jitsu so now they can be part
of mainstream society and talk
intelligently about what they see on
television or what's going on on espn
today right they have some knowledge so
they they have an identity and also
there's a good culture in jiu jitsu
where it's becoming a family you know
the dojo is the family place you go to
feel good you go to see your friends you
go to get fit and you have a good time
right so it makes a lot of sense why
it's growing
judo on the other hand i think is a
better sport for children to do it's
more
i would say
fun and interactive it's a little easier
to teach the kids how to do the throwing
skills and for safety and things like
that their body can handle more than the
adults can they're less likely to get
injured
you know they can it makes them better
athletes because it's a lot more
three-dimensional in my opinion
you know um so i think there's a good
fit between
judo can thrive from kids till
you know whatever high school
college jiu jitsu thrives from that 18
year old up right right now that's kind
of where it is
so as a dojo you have to kind of focus
on the the teens and the college like
early 20s
that kind of or you need to have if
you're going to be a successful judo
dojo you have to have that recreational
fundamental adult program in your school
where people actually come to judo learn
the moves but aren't pushed into randori
training and pushed into things where
they're uncomfortable and they can't
control the situation
because there's too many unknowns
you